how we work
how we innovate
how we interact have all changed
dramatically in the recent past
today i am excited to dive into learning
how innovation
and our new style of hybrid work
interact
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
i am very excited to chat with glenn
carroll and michael arena glenn is the
adams distinguished professor of
management at stanford gsb
glenn teaches leading through culture
and is the co-author of making great
strategy arguing for organizational
advantage
michael arena is a faculty member in
penn's masters in organizational
dynamics program
michael most recently served as the vice
president of talent and development at
amazon web services and he authored the
book adaptive space how gm and other
companies are positively disrupting
themselves and transforming into agile
organizations
welcome glenn and michael thanks for
being here i am looking so forward to
our conversation it's a pleasure to be
here really looking forward to the
conversation matt excellent let's get
started the pandemic caused a huge shift
to virtual and hybrid work you both
along with other colleagues recently
wrote a paper entitled the adaptive
hybrid innovation with virtual work
michael what research question were you
setting out to address with this work
yeah it's really interesting matt if you
would have said
pre-march 2020
that we would have all entered into this
virtual experiment together and would
have been
as productive if not more productive in
the virtual context i think many
managers and many of us who've studied
social capital and connections would
have laughed out loud but it turns out
that that is exactly what happened
mostly productivity improved or at least
remain the same for knowledge workers
but that led us really quickly to
another question a longer term question
which had much more to do with
innovation like
what will happen long term from an
innovation standpoint as it relates to
working virtually and we know from
previous research that that requires a
different set of connections than being
productive and it turns out those
particular connections are very very
fragile so so let us down this path of
really trying to understand what might
be happening with innovation longer term
and we started to really study the
network patterns quite comprehensively
to see what was emerging virtually
during that period of time and then we
started to see some anecdotes my
favorite and most alarming was in the
video game industry just as the video
game industry was at its height you know
all of our children were sent home and
you know we were all sucking up
bandwidth on our home internet systems
and the kids wanted to be playing games
because the educators hadn't caught up
you know we started to see launch delays
in the video game industry
and i think the number was there were 4x
more delays in the virtual world than
pre-covered against the standard
benchmark and we just started to become
suspicious are we still generating ideas
at the same velocity and are we able to
integrate new solutions and new products
and scale them on the back end and that
got you know glenn and myself interested
in really trying to dig deep into what
might be happening with innovation i
have two teenage sons and they were very
eager for new video game releases and
who knew video games could inspire such
interesting creative research
glenn in order to understand the
adaptive hybrid work model that you all
put forth we really first need to
understand the different stages of
innovation can you explain the different
stages and give us some insight into
them sure so we use a fairly standard
depiction of organizational innovation
that has three steps first step is what
people call ideation which is where you
brainstorm and kick around ideas and
come up with what you think is a good
idea
that's usually a pretty unstructured
process where you put people in a room
and just try to get them to interact
the second stage is what's often called
incubation
and the incubation phase is when you've
decided on one two or three ideas
and you're trying to put them in place
in an actual market or organization and
see how they perform and try to
fine-tune the way in which you're doing
it so that it works the way you want and
that the consumers understand it and
react to it the way you think they
should
and then the third stage is if you've
successfully incubated an idea it's to
bring it to scale and bring it to scale
means to bring it to the full
organization and all of its markets
products and services that are
appropriate so that you can reap the
benefits the innovation in your regular
performance so it's all about ideation
incubation and scale thank you for that
glenn your model also looks at bonding
and bridging can you help us understand
how these two concepts interact with the
stages of innovation
sure so we talk about what we call
bonding ties and bridging ties which are
social connections among individuals and
if you think about a group of
individuals who are very closely
connected to each other meaning they
have lots of different dimensions to
their relationships and they interact
with each other regularly and they kind
of know what's going on and there's a
lot of feedback and reciprocation from
that that's a bonding situation those
are bonding ties people feel close
together feel like a family feel like a
team
bridging ties on the other hand are ties
that stretch across
vast parts of your social world in this
case organizations so a bridging tie
would be someone in manufacturing might
reach out to someone in marketing or in
sales or something like that who they
don't normally interact with but they're
bridging across lots of different groups
and lots of different parts of the
organization in order to communicate
with each other bridging ties tend to be
much less frequent and much less intense
but are also important for innovation
and what we try to describe in the paper
is the way i think most social
scientists would think about how these
networks interface with the different
stages of innovation in the first one
the ideation phase you're talking about
bringing together people from all
different parts of the organization and
having them interact with each other and
so they're actually bridging and
connecting and making ideas flow from
one part of the organization to another
in ways that they might not normally so
the typical kind of interaction be a
water cooler conversation interaction
where you're talking about the warriors
game tonight and you happen to talk
about where you're parking and that
leads to a conversation about tires
let's say and then about you know one
thing leads to another so but people are
connecting because they come from
different worlds and they're bridging
across different parts of the
organization the second phase of
innovation the incubation phase is when
you're very focused and you've chosen an
idea and you take your team and you say
we want to put this idea into place and
try it out and so the team is trying to
be very focused very efficient and to
try and do what they can to make it work
and so those are usually a team that
works together a lot and the bonding
ties there help them execute very
effectively and then in the third phase
the scaling phase the person or the team
that's actually incubated the idea
successfully tries to take it up to the
larger party organization and usually
needs help in terms of getting resources
and getting people to give them access
to different parts of the organization
and markets that they don't normally
have access to and so those again
involve bridging ties but this time
rather than bridging laterally as might
be the case in ideation we're just
talking to people at the same level
organization in the scaling phase
usually are upward to people with
authority who have resources and who
could open up doors for you to get the
thing in place wow so it's quite a
matrix that gets created here and the
way in which relationships and
networking happens matters a lot i can
see based on the different phases so
michael i think we have all the pieces
in place now can you elaborate for us on
this adaptive hybrid work model that you
have created and suggest the best ways
we can optimize innovation in a hybrid
world yeah yeah absolutely and really
just to build up on what glenn just went
through
the research that we went out and
embarked upon across multiple companies
suggested to us that the type of social
capital in a virtual world showed up
differently and in other words and i'll
go way back to the beginning of our
conversation
bonding social capital actually
increased immediately
into the pandemic with our closest
colleagues it actually went up as much
as 40 percent you know wow more distant
colleagues there's been some research
out there to maybe at least is an
increase of 20 percent but that is also
the same kind of social capital you
would think about not only for
incubation but for productivity so our
hypothesis and we've got sense good
substantiating evidence on this was that
productivity increased because our
closest connection zoom is really good
for bringing you know your five to seven
closest colleagues together
and so we didn't miss a b in the area of
productivity turns out incubation was
also
positively affected during the initial
stages of the
pandemic however the opposite side of
that are bridging connections that glenn
talked about dropped off radically
dropped off a cliff about 30 in
literally the first few months which is
what
made us suspicious about can we continue
to ideate across the organization as
we've lost these bridging connections
and then with the video game industry
are we able to scale on the back end and
synchronize these things up for formal
endorsement without the appropriate
bridging connections and that is
essentially what the paper is about i
think a lot about lee fleming's work up
at harvard what it takes to discover new
ideas from a social network standpoint
is the exact opposite of what it takes
to build those ideas and that's the core
premise of the research we've got to
think through very fluidly what stage of
work are we in as we're trying to
innovate like are we at the beginning
stage of a new idea or new innovation
and do we need bridging connections or
are we in the middle are we building or
are we trying to scale and the adaptive
hybrid is basically
suggesting that we need to be much more
adaptive in the way we think about
hybrid work it's perhaps the most
foolish advice
in my opinion i'm not going to speak for
glenn although i believe he believes
this as well is to say come back in the
office two to three days a week to me
that's like playing social lottery you
know you increases your chances of
connecting with people but it's not very
deliberate at all if you're not there
when you need to be there with other
teams that you're dependent on you don't
really increase your odds all that
significantly so what we're arguing for
in the paper is an adaptive hybrid that
says you've got to ask two core
questions what work stage are you in
based on those three phases of
innovation and then secondly how much
social capital and what kind of social
capital do you have stored up
and our premise is based on those two
questions you may choose to work
virtually because you've got stored up
social capital or you may choose to come
in the office but doing it super
deliberately with the other groups you
need to interact with the advice is to
look at what's going on at a meta level
to understand where you're at in terms
of the process and then think about that
social capital the way in which we need
to connect with people and leverage our
social network at work to accomplish the
goals and in some ways
that sounds like a lot of extra work but
it sounds like it's work that's very
well worth it because it allows you to
then make sure you're maximizing for
where you're at at that point in time so
besides the two questions that you posed
michael i'm wondering are there other
things that managers leaders can be
looking for to help maximize the
likelihood that they're actually going
to be successful innovating yeah the
questions matter immensely i also think
that there's not a prescription for this
like the easy thing to do is to want to
hardwire this and build a prescription
we've got to experiment our way here the
other practical advice i would give to
leaders
is you got to use really high judgment
and go run some experiments use
different interventions decide when
you're going to come in the office and
which three teams you may pull together
and which intervention will work best
and what i've seen a lot in businesses
is also play with what virtual tools
might work the most practical advice is
trust your instincts and use high
judgment and then the second one is
experiment experiment experiment it
would be easy for glenn and i and others
to come out and say you need this
intervention or you need that
intervention but that may not work for
your company what we're really trying to
challenge leaders to do
is to use that high judgment and then
experiment like crazy with the
interventions that work most with their
teams a big theme i'm hearing from what
you and glenn are talking about is this
notion of we have to be flexible setting
rigid guidelines and boundaries might
work against innovation and more
opportunistic types of interactions
i can't miss this opportunity to talk to
glenn and not bring up the topic of
authenticity authenticity is a topic
that we've talked a lot about on this
podcast and it plays a large role i
believe in communication and lots of
other areas so glenn i am curious to
learn your thoughts about the role of
authenticity in communication and how we
can actively work to be more authentic
it's one of the first bits of advice
most people receive when they come to
their communication or somebody to help
them with their communication they say
okay just be your authentic self i'm
just curious what are your thoughts on
that so i think i have a pretty
straightforward answer to your question
matt
and my answer would be that someone is
an authentic communicator when they are
the same person in public
speaking that they are in private that
is you don't see a change in the
character the demeanor or even the
things the person says they're really
the same person
and i think if you say someone's an
authentic communicator that's a great
compliment because it says that they're
really natural when they're speaking in
public and they're not going to tell you
something different than they would have
in private yeah interesting so being
that same person speaking the same way i
don't know if you have any data on this
glenn but i'm just curious
when we all move to virtual
communicating or communicating in an
intermediated way i think a lot of us
became inauthentic just because we had
so much to pay attention to i mean we've
got all these
volumes and buttons and all this
do you have any instinct as to
the difficulty that virtual
communication had on authenticity or its
impact on authenticity so i don't have
any data and i haven't seen any really
good research on that i mean my
impression is pretty similar to yours i
think that a lot of people became what i
would consider much more artificial when
they're online than they were in person
on the other hand you see the same thing
you know when people get up and speak in
person sometimes it's not just a virtual
setting where you see that you think
like wow that's a different person i've
had people say well i don't know just
something happens and i become a
different person when i'm speaking i
don't necessarily think that's a bad
thing some people are probably better
communicators when they're doing that
but it does make you wonder what's going
on that makes the person change
absolutely well maybe there's some
research and collaboration that we can
do on that because i'm fascinated by how
the environment influences people's
authenticity
before we end i'd like to ask both of
you the same three questions i ask
everybody who joins me are you guys up
for that yeah absolutely excellent all
right we'll start with you glenn if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you have ever received as a five
to seven word presentation slide title
what would it be so i'm going to sound
like i'm pandering but uh this is really
true matt so i was watching one of your
videos and you were talking about people
got nervous when they speak
yeah and your advice was just reflect at
that moment and tell yourself oh that's
just me being nervous and in fact you
know if i had known that when i was much
younger i think it would have helped me
with a lot of anxiety i had in public
speaking it really is true once you just
realize like this is a normal thing and
this is still you
that it relaxes you entirely pandering
will get you everywhere glenn no i'm
glad that that advice was helpful and
it's helpful to many of us to take a
moment to just realize that anxiety is
pervasive in fact it is the norm to not
be nervous is the stranger of the
situation i'm glad that's helpful for
you and i hope it's helpful for others
as well michael i'm curious who is a
communicator that you admire and why i
think i want to say mary bara because i
had the chance of working with mary
barra as glenn has while i was at
general motors she's just a really
unique communicator in ways that i
admire tremendously and she's super
authentic awesome listener which i think
is an under
represented part of communicating right
just an incredible listener who draws
other people in and then is i actually
think quite masterful at synthesizing
what she just heard from many many
others so for me like when i'm thinking
about leadership and communication not
standing on the stage and communicating
but leadership in communicating she
rises to the top to me
i love that i asked a question about a
communicator and you immediately went to
a leader who's very good at listening
and synthesizing we often forget that
that's a critical part of communication
glenn i'd like to ask you the same
question who is a communicator that you
admire and why yeah so i'm going to go
in the other direction here but somebody
i don't know and i've really only heard
speak once and that was on television
and that is amanda gorman she's a young
poet laureate she read a poem at joe
biden's inauguration i mean i remember
watching it she had so much confidence
and i was just amazed at her maybe 21
years old i was amazed at her ability to
do this and so it was a matter of her
oration and not necessarily a two-way
communication but it was very very
powerful
absolutely i was very moved by that as
well she's she's a very gifted
communicator and was able in that moment
to really bring i think a lot of people
to that same conclusion you came to
thank you so michael third question for
you
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe i'll get a little unconventional
on this one too so in social science
there's something called the gossip and
reputation cycle
and it's basically how a message will be
picked up and carried if you want to
think about it virally across the
network for me i think about it this way
it's got to be short it's got to be a
snippet because we communicate to others
in snippets it won't carry if it's not
short it's got to be compelling like if
it's not meaningful no one's going to
repeat it and it's not going to travel
across the network and probably most
importantly is it's got to be
interesting to the person you're
communicating to i'm never going to
repeat something that someone else says
if i can't find something in it that was
interesting to me or relevant to the
audience is another way of thinking
about that those are the three things i
think about is short meaningful and
interesting to the audience or the
individual that you're communicating to
who knew we could learn so much from
gossip in terms of what makes for
effective communication but certainly
being concise making sure it's
meaningful and interesting and relevant
make a big difference
i certainly want to make sure that the
work that you two do is not seen as
gossip but is seen as as very critical
and i've really enjoyed the conversation
your adaptive hybrid model i think is
really informative for all businesses to
think about as we navigate our way
through this and really your mantra of
experiment try learn how to make this
work for an individual organization
really makes a lot of sense i thank you
very much for your time and for your
insights thank you thank you man
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by michael
reilly jenny luna and me matt abrahams
find more resources and join in the
conversation by searching linkedin for
think fast talk smart
download and subscribe wherever you find
your podcasts
you